pour foire messieurs merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france cette crise
ouverte entre la france et l'algérie est
ce que c'est un mepi phénomène ou bien
c'est grave farid daoud ce débat
mais écoutez moi j'y vois surtout à un
calendrier électoral
monsieur macron sachant que si on veut
revenir un petit peu en arrière et les
se rappeler un petit peu de mâcon
candidats à l'époque où il avait parlé
d'un crime contre l'humanité justement
la colonisation française en algérie
donc bon là c'est un petit peu bis
repetita ce mais il se suit un petit peu
c'est la course à l'échalote après
zemmour donc il a un petit peu sur fait
de la surenchère avec cette histoire de
visa et est derrière ben voilà soi
disant il ya justement un petit peu
d'écrits d'effaroucher derrière enfin
c'est plus des gesticulations de la part
du 2 du gouvernement algérien derrière
qui joue un jeu de te tue il faut pas il
faut pas se leurrer avec avec la france
depuis des années la france et l'algérie
cas les gouvernements algérien et
français sont dans dans la main emmanuel
macron candidat a oublié sa promesse de
candidat pour totalement mettre aux
oubliettes qui goûte une même unité donc
contact derrière il sort bien sur cette
interview dans le monde oui qualifient
les uns je cite de une histoire
officielle totalement réécrit ne
s'appuient pas sur des vérités et aussi
il voit enfin macron il dit je vois
parlant de te boom qu'il est pris dans
un système qui est réduit retient donc
quel système de quoi il parle j'aimerais
bien justement qu il soit un petit peu
plus carré sur ses déclarations donc
pour moi c'est un petit peu un jeu de
dupes mc on utilise un petit peu voilà
ce set cet épisode pour se moucher en
tant que candidat donc il va dans le
sens de la diaspora enfin des les
français d'origine algérienne ou des bi
nationaux et 2 côté bar le gouvernement
enfin
algérien
montre les muscles un bomber le torse
voilà en disant nous sommes les plus
forts nous fermons l'espace aérien mais
tout ça c'est que de la com éthique de
parts et d'autres il faut saveurs et je
vais finir là-dessus que la france ne
peut pas se permettre justement de 2,2
mal fonctionné avec le gouvernement
algérien dans le sens que il suffit
juste de voir c'est pas d'importation de
des hydrocarbures le pétrole représente
12 % de lait par algérienne et le gaz
n'a cessé d'augmenter en période de
crise du gaz en france alors le gaz
représentent 10% des achats
de la france à l'algérie donc peu pâli
peuvent pas se permettre de se mettre
l'algérie à nous et l'algérie derrière
le gouvernement ne peuvent pas se
permettre de se mettre le gouvernement
français à dos parce qu'il faut savoir
que les bandits qui sont au pouvoir
algérien sont justement maintenu au
pouvoir algérien grâce justement à la
coopération française grâce au
gouvernement et au soutien du
gouvernement français de toulouse boon
est arrivé au pouvoir dernière c'était
tapis rouge le drian on dirait que sa
maison de campagne et alger du surf hors
d'algérie déplacement officiel d'accord
vous êtes d'accord avec l'analyse le
point de vue de farid benstiti bah
je vais quand même apporté quelques
nuances et quelques éclaircissements
tout d'abord il ya vraiment là un
tournant dans les relations entre
l'algérie et la france moi même j'étais
témoin de cette relation entre
1986 et 2008 où j'ai accompagné des
entreprises françaises de la région en
algérie régulièrement il ya toujours eu
chez les dirigeants français une
pression de la part d'un lobby qui
existe un lobby français en france qui
constituaient des harkis qui constitué
de ceux qui ont qui ont l'honneur la
nostalgie de l'algérie france et
puis la droite réactionnaire il faut le
dire ensuite il y a les candidats que ce
soit françois hollande que ce soit
emmanuel macron ils se sont adressés en
termes très apaisé un électorat
algeria et maghrébins dans des termes
très convenue c'est à dire condamné le
colonialisme les crimes coloniaux et
cetera là on est dans une autre phase
signifie que la france droitise et ses
extrêmes droites is même et que le
président candidat en fait là il agit
tout ce qu'il a dit la lecture de
l'histoire algérienne aux écrits
personnels mois un livre là-dessus je
suis pas historien mais j'ai fait une
analyse pense qu'ils aient partagé mais
je suis un expert je fais pas président
de la république et je peux m'exprimer
librement monsieur macro lille et
président de la république et quand ils
s'expriment ils chatouillent un peu il
ya toujours une réaction qui souvent
disproportionnées vous savez que
l'algérie a rappelé son ambassadeur
suite à un document
les propos relayés par le monde des
manuels à mâcon c'est un dérapage vous
estimez ou pas par rapport à l'aller
c'est lui le président français depuis
le début de son mandat pour justement
apaiser les relations avec l'algérie
ternie par les rancoeurs du passé
colonial
c'est un dérapage il y a entendu un
président de la république et d'une
l'ancienne puissance
colonisatrice ne devrait pas tenir ces
propos là ils sont ils peuvent être ils
peuvent émaner d'experts historiens de
jean d'essayiste qui non content de
rendre de comptes à rendre à personne
mais là là c'est pas emmanuel macron
président qui skie kiki pas c'est
emmanuel macron candidats et candidats
fassent acquis face à eric zemmour qui
critiquent le magret les critiques les
musulmans l'immigration on connaît le
thème de et eric zemmour moi j'ai une
hypothèse personnelle c'est que le
président macron il a tout intérêt à
voir ou deuxième tours plus tôt et
l'eczéma là il va gagner plutôt que même
marine le pen donc là par contre ce qui
est nouveau c'est qu'il tient pas compte
du tout du régime et du pouvoir algérien
est l'image que vous me revenir à lisa
mascagni ya des liens et l'écrasent il
prend pas en compte ces réactions il
réduit les les visas et dit ce furent
justement l'accent
sur la réduction des visas est-ce que ça
c'est une mesure à avize électorale
selon vous farid dame ce débat parce que
c'est une mesure en tout cas que leur
avait ni l'algérie et la tunisie on
imagine le maroc non mais c'est une
vaste blague cette histoire de visa
franchement franchement vous pensez
sérieusement un instant que le pouvoir
algérien a que faire des visas on
attribua aux algériens la plupart déjà
des gens de cette mafia en algérie ont
déjà la double nationalité que ce soit
française ou d'un autre pays et en plus
de ça leurs familles qui sont censés
être visité en algérie
on le sait très bien nérac se bat contre
qui à l'heure actuelle quand le cracker
en février 2019 se soulèvent ces contre
justement un cinquième mandat contre
bouteflika mais aussi pour ce slogan qui
dit ça veut dire qu'on retire courge
tire la chasse et on recommence sur des
bases saines pour un état de droit pour
la véritable liberté un bis avec des
règles et pas seulement tabbee dirigé
par la justice du téléphone on sait très
bien et a des il ya des exactions nazies
génie paris des débats vous ne savez que
les propos d' emmanuel macron c'est
aussi interprété par le gouvernement
algérien comme justement
un soutien au mouvement durable non mais
c'est un jeu de dupes si macron voulais
était un amoureux de la justice de la
liberté il se serait rangé dès le départ
du côté du peuple algérien il a eu que
faire du peuple algérien dès le début il
a envoyé ses ministres pour faire son
marché en algérie l'algérie est juste
bon pour les contrats il est juste bon
pour les hydrocarbures le peuple on s'en
fout il ya des 1000 des centaines enfin
des dizaines l'a récemment de harraga
des pauvres personnes qui se sont noyées
en méditerranée ils en ont que faire de
ça ils s'en foutent du peuple algérien
comme le gouvernement algérien s'en fout
de son peuple
macron veut signer des contrats veut que
les hydrocarbures fonctionne toujours
dans un sens cela il va faire froid
l'augmentation du gaz les 10% de de la
part algérienne il faut surtout pas
qu'ils se la met à dos et derrière le
gouvernement algérien il a bien sûr des
millions et des millions d'euros voire
peut-être plus d'investissements en
france et si on voulait vraiment savoir
et mettre le nez dans les magouilles de
ces gouvernements algériens j'entends et
ben justement y aurait peut-être des ddd
juge je mettrais un petit peu le nez
dans les affaires à d'investissement de
cette mafia et au niveau de 2,2 de la
france donc il suffit un petit peu de
prendre les gens pour des imbéciles
la france le gouvernement français a
fait et où heureux de ce qui se passe en
algérie parce que ça ne touche pas ses
affaires ça ne touche pas son business
ça ne touche pas soit hydrocarbures son
pré carré algérien est toujours
maintenue et le côté bas pour un petit
peu aller ce jeu là on va dire sur
redorer le blason se créer une nouvelle
j'ai d'imiter ben gouvernement algérien
qui est affaiblie par le chirac il faut
le rappeler deux ans presque trois ans
de deux manifestations à barrière sans
les gros muscles j on va fermer l'espace
aérien alors
pour la décision du gouvernement
algérien sur la décision du jeune
arrière de fermer l'espace son espace
aérien aux avions militaires français en
partance pour le sel on sait que quand
même l'algérie c'est quand même à un
acteur majeur de la lutte antiterroriste
au sahel qui est partie prenante aussi
dans les accords d'alger dans les
efforts de stabilisation au mali est ce
que c'est une décision finalement lourd
de conséquences pour la sécurité dans la
région au fait elle pour la france aussi
qui est déjà en froid ans et avec le
gouvernement malien maintenant
je non je ne pense pas c'est à face à va
techniquement il y aura détournement des
avions français vont passer par d'autres
espaces aériens ça va coûter un peu plus
cher mais ça c'est contribuables
français qui va payer mais s'ils vont
poursuivre concernant le positionnement
de l'algérie au niveau du du sahel en ou
connaissant très bien le double jeu du
pouvoir algérien et deux militaires moi
j'ai défendu toujours depuis le début du
day irak dans tous les médias j'avais
dit que le régime algérien c'est un
régime militaire et que j'ai je
l'expliqué bien dans mon livre donc ce
régime là et il est il a un double jeu
au niveau du sahel il a permis aux
groupes terroristes
et c'est écrit dans un rabattant
beaucoup de journaux algériens il a
permis aux
volumes 9 et 10 mai n'a pas pas de
poursuivre leurs activités dans le sahel
mais à condition de ne pas toucher le
sud algérien et la richesse algérienne
qui concentraient dans les puits de gaz
et de pétrole dans cette région ça a été
le seul à seul exception c'était la
prise de d'otages dans les chaudes
du sud mais il ya toujours ce modus
vivendi le double jeu du pouvoir
algérien et en plus elle est le
nageur qui militaire qui gouverne
réellement l'algérie avant il y avait à
une présidence qu'il existait 7 et
boutef des cas mais ensuite maintenant
ils ont tous les pouvoirs
ils ont tout intérêt à ce qu'ils aient
encore des problèmes avec nomao qu'avec
le sud 2-2 de l'algérie pour susciter le
pouvoir algérien la mainmise de pouvoir
algérien et il a c'est une fuite en
avant qui vont parce qu'ils n'ont pas le
choix il n'y a pas de solution aux
problèmes du peuple algérien merci
camille sari est un essayiste
c'est la diversification économique et
le planant claude pour le peuple
essayiste et auteur et merci également à
vous phare evans débat fondateur du
mouvement citoyen pour l'algérie